dominique robert badinter bonsoir la
france a connu affirme barbie bousquet
assassiné la fille retrouviez juger
maintenant papon quelles leçons peut-on
tirer de toutes ces affaires aujourd'hui
à la contenu ce qui se passe d'abord en
ce qui concerne papon un mot simplement
j'ai bien fait dire que l'exil de nom et
ce paletot rigaux c'est la fuite qui est
tout simplement la fuite devant la
justice je rappelle que demain c'est la
plus haute juridiction française qui
doit se prononcer et dieu sait que
maurice papon a pu utiliser tous les
moyens de défense
par conséquent c'est tout simplement la
fuite et je mesure ce que cela signifie
pour les victimes
alors en ce qui concerne une réflexion
d'ensemble sur ces procès crimes contre
l'humanité pour les jeunes gens et je
dirais même ceux qui sont moins jeunes
c'est des mots mais ces procès ont
permis ce qui est appréciable de mesurer
ce que signifient les mots crimes contre
l'humanité on a vu les visages des
victimes
vous vous rappelez la photographie des
enfants d'izieu on a entendu les
victimes
on a compris ce que signifiait
l'arrestation la déportation et le camp
de concentration et à partir de cela
pendant ces années écoulées
je suis convaincu que grâce à ses procès
avec toutes les difficultés et tous les
déboires qu'ils ont pu susciter il
demeure que l'on a mesuré qu'il n'était
pas possible que dans notre monde on
accepte l'impunité des criminels contre
l'humanité et à ce titre c'est procéda
ont préparé cette prise de conscience
avec l'émergence que l'on voit
maintenant les tribunaux de la haine et
la cour pénale internationale donc
indiscutablement ils ont servi la cause
de la justice
maintenant je comprends encore une fois
ce que chacune des victimes peut
ressentir en mesurant que papon
disparaît ils ont manqué c'est donc je
procès ont été utiles mais pour pape ont
finalement c'est quoi et écouter pour
tapons moi je comprend bien pourquoi les
magistrats ont été
je dirais scrupuleux jusqu'à l'extrême
jusqu'à le placer en liberté afin qu'on
ne puisse pas dire qu'il n'ait pas
bénéficié de tous les moyens de sa
défense parce que ces décisions là qui
sont des décisions qui entre dans
l'histoire
elles doivent être irréprochables et
c'est le cas pour seul de papon alors
vous devrez bon japon il a disparu
seulement c'est vrai qu'il ait disparu
mais demain la cour de cassation se
prononcera
et si comme on le pense des choix pas
bande son pourvoi ou si elle le rejette
nous verrons bien
qu'est ce qui reste qu'est ce que sera
pas pondre et 9 ans c'est un homme
condamné condamné par la justice de son
pays après avoir eu toutes les chances
de sa défense pour crimes contre
l'humanité
pape on sait dorénavant un criminel
contre l'humanité
stigmatisés et papon c'est un homme en
fuite
papon c'est un homme qui sera traqué
papon partout où il ira mandat d'arrêt
international pourra jouer contre lui et
papon jeudi au terme de cette vie ce
sera un lâche merci robert badinter